it's a little Maddie needs to start his
leash and harness training I mean I know
some of you guys might have seen this
video already there's gonna be his first
attempt chillin on a leash he was not
into this one because I couldn't get his
ol head through it mmm see it's almost
too tiny good boy I got a pink a pink
leash okay here we go
you're very confused aren't you it's
okay it's okay we're doing some
expedited training so we can travel
shortly it's okay you can walk am come
on there's a little snack for you
nothing please can we please go for a
walk come on come on let's go yeah let's
go you're not good at this okay let's
just take off this leash and let you run
her on your little harness and see how
that works
we gotta get him we got to get him being
a good puppy
I know all the way videos are about the
dog but that's all it is going on I have
a new playpen for him that I saw online
have really high reviews so Maddie we
got new something outside
he said sick of my shenanigans mercy
yeah we'll get him in the shot right now
there are pieces try to play call of
duty and Altan dog is hiding of the cup
Matt come here this is not good
Maddie
[Music]
people's my hair no you're gonna give me
split ends big maddie let's set up a
Playstation do you want to help me I
need help I can't do by myself I can't
do it by myself
actually I do apologize for the lack of
videos I actually do have a couple
cooking videos I hope I had filmed
previous to getting him so as soon as I
get those edited I will have those up
for you guys I will say having a dog has
changed my life quite a significant way
because I can't do whatever I want
anymore
it's all about you basically the updates
holy moly it's like excuse you you
haven't turned me on forever
a little man sleeping doesn't even want
to wait to play the game with me welcome
back to PlayStation it's been a year and
a half
oopsie what is happening over here you
still asleep you're such a little mess I
just I can't even get over you oh my
gosh I should put you in your cage but I
just can't I can't bear to be away from
you where's your other foot I hear
there's we've got all four look at this
sleepy little baby
what well clearly I don't think I'll be
playing this tonight or tomorrow or even
the next day so where's my little
teeny-tiny may enact hey we gotta go
pick up Lizzy we're gonna meet Lizzy
it's gonna be your new friend you've got
so many friends he likes to hide into me
now I can't find it come on let's go
let's go you just like roll you out she
come out rolling you out of here man
about town let's go let's go come on hey
so I'm not sure what this vlog was it's
basically just a bunch of clips of me
and my new pup we made it through our
first week together and I'm very proud
to announce that he does know how to
nose house so let's just demonstrate and
I hope you guys have a good day I'm so
tired I have a headache I'm not sure I
think I'm dehydrated her maybe here I'm
not sure I think puppy has taken a tool
no we gotta make sure her in the shot
[Music]
this is Maddie he's a good dog he's a
real sweet soul he's taking all of my
energy I can't imagine having a child
honestly you know your mom talked to you
his little teeth are coming in real nice
he makes me really happy you too
I would never let you down thanks for
watching guys I hope you enjoy Maddie he
makes me a happy happy little person
[Music]